How's it going bros?
This is Pewdiepie!
*fixing hair like a boss
So, I was gonna record a video today,
but......
I just don't have the strength
or the energy to really do it.
My buddy Ken was here a week ago ,
and that fucker got me sick.
Hey Ken. Fuck you.
*kiss*
So I've been sick for a week,
And I've been trying to get the videos out anyway and...
Really forcing it to work, but
Today I just feel like I can't be bothered.
I just-
Yeah.
So instead of getting half ass shitty video you get a half ass shitty video but in an honest way
Isn't that right, Edgar?
Well, fuck off then.
I realised I haven't taken a day off for being sick since I started making videos,
which is kinda weird.
I really love doing the videos and I hate to miss a day coz I'm just not feeling well.
This video is literally just me feeling bad, sorry for myself,
like, "oh no, poor me".
Literally I just want to get back on my feet again. I wanna be healthy again,
and I'm sick of being sick.
You ever feel like that?
You still go to school, so I bet not.
So yeah I decided to do an update vlog instead again.
A lot of people seem to be concerned about my health lately,
Because I seem skinnier but I think its because I just shaved the beard.
I'm not doing cocaine...
at the moment.
I also started working out when I got my beard,
So once I shaved I think I lost a little bit of weight,
And thats why I look like.
You can actually see my cheekbones now. That wasnt a thing before.
I'm surprised as well.
And thats another reason why I'm fed up with being sick,
is that I can't exercise.
What I discovered that exercising is really important to me,
Because it takes out so much stress from YouTube.
Oh my God, I did it again.
YouTube is so hard!
It's not.
I'm sure you noticed I'm on the new set-up.
The sound is garbage.
I'm working on it. Thank you for being patient.
A lot of comments are saying, "Wow your new office looks so cool, Pewds!"
There's nothing. It's just the room. There's literally nothing to compliment.
I will do a set-up video once we're fully set up.
I think that will be really cool.
I want to make this space a little bit more personal.
Like, I spray-painted the last place.
I wanna have a personal touch on my videos.
And yes I still live with Marzia. Michael helps me out with the videos just like Brad does.
And I use this space as an office I dont actually live here.
I still live with Marzia. We're still together.
You can calm the fuck down thank you very much.
I hate being sick. *laughs*
I used to love being sick. When did this change?
I guess when you really love what you do, that really changes your perspectives on things.
But yeah, I dont record in my house because of the same reason I got kicked out of my other office.
You never know what's gonna happen,
and my videos are loud,
and there's gotta be problems.
British people are so fucking passive-aggressive.
It's weird.
So far, no landlord has been knocking on the door outside,
So I think that's pretty good.
I think thats a good sign.
I wanna say thank you for supporting the channel.
There's really has been an increase in the amount of people watching,
which is really crazy to me,
because I thought this channel peaked long ago,
it has.
But it's still going up,
That to me is incredible.
Because you see, past YouTubers that gone big fast,
theyre gone down even faster.
And for me to maintain an audience,
and keep doing what I'm doing,
it really means a lot to me,
and I really appreciate you guys are watching.
And i think it's because the content has improved,
and I owe that to Brad and Michael,
who help me out with the videos,
coming up with ideas and
I think thats really good.
It's really fun for me to work with other people,
thats really rich of me to say content has improved
when i'm literally making the worst video ever right now
The laziest one, at least.
It's like in the last phase of this sickness, I feel like I need another day,
then I'm gonna be fine.
So i'm gonna go fap,
Thank you guys so much for supporting me,
I really appreciate it,
and I'm sorry for this garbage ass video,
and I'll see you bros tomorrow.
Hopefully i'll be back on my feet then,
And as always, stay awesome bros!
*BROFISTS*
(ty for having the subtitles on)
(ty to pewds for being awesome and making videos even when he's sick)
(bye bye)